hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
this is a continuation of our
educational series on
fundamentals of signal processing and
audio measurements
this is a simpler topic tonight on
dynamic range
it's an important topic because it
declare it tells us how noisy a system
is and
noise is quite audible we could argue
about whether distortion is audible
but you can hear noise put you here next
to a speaker if the amplifier is noisy
you'll hear noise so we want to measure
that always want to know how clean our
uh
audio system is with respect to noise
production
so one common test that i run it has two
names signal noise ratio or dynamic
range i won't get into a distinction for
now but
but assume they're both the same thing
for the purpose of this discussion
and i have my audio precision analyzer
running the
piece of hardware was used for audio
measurements this is the user interface
for it
somebody asked what is this software
this software goes with that hardware
they do sell this software by itself
that you can connect to your own sound
card
but it's extremely expensive i think
it's three thousand dollars for the base
software and then price goes up from
there so i don't know that you want to
invest in
in this piece of software but it's
available anyway
i've told the audio precision analyzer
to connect this input to its output
i've set the signal level to four volts
and
set the frequency to one kilohertz
that's the convention
we use one kilohertz tone and if i tell
it to run
it takes a couple of seconds and it
produces this uh display that you see
and then excuse me 133 db and change
what does this number mean that means if
whatever our noise floor
is our signal relative to that that 4
volt signal
is 133 decibels higher
okay so if you were to listen to this
system
at this kind of loudness 133 db heat
loudness which is exceptionally loud you
go def
the noise floor would be a zero db spl
okay so that's
the range we're talking so this
obviously is phenomenal
uh we don't need 133 db because we don't
listen at 120 db
at 133 db but if we did this system
would be nearly silent our threshold
of hearing is actually 10 db below zero
so this is really equivalent to 123 it's
still
exceptional and as it should be this is
an expensive piece of equipment designed
for
instrumentation now the number that i
picked in here is important i put in
four volts in here uh notice what
happens uh
when i put one volt in there and run the
same test
we dropped a ton in here so we went from
133 to 121.
why is that the reason for that is that
the noise of the instrument or the
output of your
preamp or dac what have you is fixed so
when we tell it to generate the one
killer's tone that's riding on top of
that
so if i set the one kilo stone at a
higher voltage let's say four volts
which i had this distance is more than
if i reduce that so the more i reduce
the voltage output of the
the audio device this smaller this ratio
becomes remember decibels the ratio
ratio of this
to this fixed noise so uh sorry i didn't
have my configuration right so this is
your fixed noise
and it does usually doesn't change there
are cases where this noise actually
signal dependent but
let's not get wrapped up around that
so the higher this voltage is the better
this number
tends to be for audio equipment so
whenever you see a dynamic range
specification you must know this number
otherwise this is a meaningless value
because if i measure two identical
pieces of equipment one is measured in
one volt the other one measured with
four volts
and i get 12 db difference that doesn't
make any sense so we
must have this specif this specification
now for the most part the standard in
industry is that if you have an rca
output of uh
you know analog device uh audio device
these should have two volts of output
maximum
so if you have a dac that has rca
connectors at the end
you get two volts output and if you have
xlr balanced
connection it should have four volts
output
almost every desktop product that i test
delivers on those they can go higher
in which case you can dial them back
down unfortunately if you have an av
receiver or home theater processor
though that industry has decided on its
own values for these things and usually
much
lower and that hurts their performance
often because they
instead of four volts they may output
2.2 volts and they get distorted above
that
so you need to have this number so
make sure you're always comparing the
right things i always standardize on
this
two volts for unbalanced if the device
i'm testing
only has on balance if i'm testing xlr
then i'll
set it to be four volts and measure that
way
so let's go back to our four volts again
and
get that old measurement so we're back
to 133 again
down here you see some additional
parameters
i've told the analyzer to apply two
filters by the way this is the default
template that ships from audio precision
so uh
more this is more of a you know industry
convention
is what they've implemented which is
we're interested in the noise
from 20 hertz to 20 000 hertz
a a piece of audio device
can have constant noise throughout the
frequency range or you could have noise
that goes up and down
so we need to decide how much of that
noise energy
we're going to capture for obvious
reasons the convention is 20 hertz at 20
000 hertz but it doesn't have to be and
indeed if you play high-res music
then you're dealing with higher sample
rates therefore
you have wider bandwidth so let's say
let's go ahead and change this
from 20 kilohertz to 90 kilohertz
now watch what happens to this number
when i run it i haven't changed anything
else
but notice how we drop down to 126. so
we lost 60 via performance now this is a
exceptional analyzer very quiet in
ultrasonics
many audio devices have much more noise
above 20 kills so if i include them
in there their performance could suffer
tremendously i mean you could see 40 50
db
drop now you have to be mindful of the
fact that we don't hear that noise
so um you know it doesn't matter should
we measure that
you know that's why by convention you
know we measure 20 kilohertz over here
okay now at
a convenient concept so these numbers
are
there and you could try to memorize 120
db 180
what does it mean you know what does it
mean in practice how do we
translate this something that makes
sense to us
um what i do which the analyzer does not
do by default i do it manually i convert
all of these dynamic range or signal
noise ratios to a
number of bits as if you had a digital
system
how many bits would that be i do that
because
all of us are familiar with cd being
16-bit format and that's the streaming
format and that's
99.9 of the content out there so it's
good to know
how our system noise floor is relative
to a 16-bit content
and uh you know we ideally
ideally hopefully we can reproduce
16-bit
audio from a cd without the system
itself adding noise to it
a 16-bit system this doesn't have
sufficient dynamic range
for the noise floor to be below our
audibility by the way
i'll again i'll cover that in a future
video but as a minimum we don't want to
add
any noise to it that we already have in
the channel in the distributed media
so it's good to know what this
translates to it bits
we know 16 bits how many bits is this
can we get that number we can and
let me bring up my browser for you here
and
turn off my video capture
there we go so if you go on wikipedia or
just
google for this thing called effective
number of bits
or e-nob as it said you can see this
wording down here e-n-o-b is the
abbreviation where effective number of
bits
if it takes it shows a sign at but
basically anytime you see a number in my
dynamic range
take that ignore this minus part and
divide divided by six
and that gives you an approximate
equivalent number of bits
that you have this is a measure usually
for analog to digital converters
and it's a way to find out if we have
uh you know what is the equivalent bits
is just because
analog digital converter says i'm a 24
bit converter doesn't mean that it
produces 24 bits worth of accurate data
it has a lot of internal noise and it
therefore generates
x amount of useful data so we steal this
concept
and then apply it to our measurements
and you see that in almost every review
that i do
so if you look at this flux
headphone amplifier f812 review that i
recently did
if you go down here you see two
measurements here the one on the left is
basically what i was showing you
i instead of using the analyzer
measuring itself in this case i was
measuring
the flux and it gives me 119
db if i divide this by six it gives me
20 bits roughly
120 db is 20 bits
20 bits means we have four more bits
worth of uh dynamic range compared to a
cd
i feel good about that in general i like
to see a dynamic range
that is 10 db better than whatever
format you play so cd at best case is 96
db
so you want to be at least 106 db um
in the system here we have more than 106
db
we've got 119 but you quickly lose track
of these
numbers right that's what we just
divided this by six and boom we got 20
bits of dynamic range
and we're golden so we know this will do
justice to cd
does it do justice to a 24-bit content
that is truly 24-bit
probably not but recordings have you
know fair amount of noise in them unless
they're computer generated anyway so
20 bits is fine state of the art is 2122
bits
um can't get any better than that
because just there's so much
inherent noise in electronics and by the
way this noise
includes my analyzer noise i cannot
there's a way to eliminate that but in
general
the number that comes up here includes
the noise of my analyzer
and my um and the device being tested
and these devices are so good uh that
some of what you're seeing here is my
analyzer at 20 bits
the device dominates but once you get to
22 bits
it's really my analyzer is noisier than
what i'm testing
for headphone amplifiers i actually make
a secondary measurement and i'll do a
a detailed walkthrough of headphone i'm
sorry headphone amplifier measurements
in the future
but for now notice that i also test the
uh
the headphone amplifier at 50 millivolts
so remember this was a four volt
uh test just like i had done in my audio
precision demo that i just gave you
but i also do another test where i take
the volume control and crank it way down
and i measure the output till it reads
roughly 50 millivolts
and then i get run the same test again
and now you see how much is dropped
substantially drops
again remember the noise is fixed so if
you
take the 4 volts and reduce it down to
just 0.05 volts
which is what 50 millivolts is now the
noise is a much bigger
uh portion of that and then we get the
dynamic range here we only have 13 bits
now obviously
we're not even at 16 bit audio best case
if you look at in this graph i plot all
these things the best case
that i've ever measured has been by the
way i should say a30 pro
is a 95 db so we can achieve
the dynamic range of uh of a cd
while playing at just 50 millivolts you
might say why do i care about 50
millivolts
well when you use in-ear monitors
these little jobbies they sit really
close to your ear canal
and they can be quite sensitive i mean
that driver doesn't need to move more
than fraction of a hair to generate
sound and so you crank the volume down
to listen to them
and when you crank the volume down
you're operating at way below four volts
uh i'm sure none of these iems you would
use as four volts
so when you do that when the music is
not playing
like it pauses or fades between tracks
you don't want to hear
hiss right i mean it's annoying to yes
you know between tracks or when the
tracks get quiet so you want this
dynamic range to be as good as you
possibly can and from anecdotal data
using this output level once you get to
90s
you're golden below 90s it can be
audible
and this device is okay but not great
you can see how bad it can get and get
down to 45 so
uh but average about 80 81 and this is
average so with this
amplifier i would say if you have very
sensitive iems
uh in your monitors you might hear some
hits
and uh you know how much bothers you
it's up to you
where do 50 mil it come from our head
i saw somebody refer to it on some of
the forms i said hey how about measuring
at 50 millivolts we picked
50 millivolts comes out to be very small
amount of wattage
you can do the math square this and
divide it by the impedance of your
headphone
and you can get that but it's a fraction
of a milliwatt so
very small amount of power but again
these little in-ear monitors
are quite sensitive and you can hear
okay so nothing too complicated but you
gotta understand the logistics of these
things this is why i mentioned that this
is four volts
in and out it's so important you can get
a dynamic range spec
from manufacturer and it won't even tell
you this number won't tell you the
bandwidth won't tell you anything
so those numbers have no meaning at all
you know if they're not giving you their
voltages as i am giving it to you it is
not useful
and uh and they need to give you the
bandwidth i need to do that too but
in this case i'm lazy and implied that
it's 20 kilos bandwidth
uh on this thing okay hopefully you
found this video useful
um i'll do more of these drill downs uh
for each one of the measurements
if i can you know put them together as a
package that makes sense like this one
as i said this is a much longer topic of
what is the dynamic range that you need
there are a lot of questions about
what's audible in the comments i get
and that's the first step in
understanding uh
you know what is the needed dynamic
range i've already given you some hints
in here as far as
threshold of hearing and what the cd
format can do but there's more to it
than that
and there's a lot of misconceptions
there okay hopefully you like this video
and uh don't mind going back to school
and
and taking these lessons uh i'll
see if i can post something on a variety
in a few
in the next video rather than all these
tutorials
okay see you in a future video bye-bye